it's been a busy year for Respawn
Entertainment in February the studio
took a left turn it announced and
simultaneously released apex legends a
free-to-play battle royale taking place
in the titanfall universe except it
didn't have Titans
despite the franchise's critical acclaim
respawn was veering away from the Mex
centric combat it had built its
reputation on and yet apex Legends was a
smash hit
within one month it had accrued 50
million total installs it also met with
widespread a duration despite drawing
many fans ire with a lack of titanfall 3
news the studio had for all intents and
purposes stepped outside of its mech
filled bubble of course the team's work
was not done as a new entry in the
growing games as service Pantheon apexis
launch has required weekly maintenance
ranging from weapon nerfs to
anti-cheating efforts to brand new
characters
what's more despite a rough first season
respawn has turned things around in the
following - its garnered devoted players
trust and seeded optimism for season 4
but for all of its momentum leading into
2019 s latter half respawn still had its
biggest challenge ahead of it releasing
a game set within the hallowed Star Wars
universe
[Music]
Star Wars Jedi fallen order joins one of
the longest and rockiest ancestries of
video games titles such as Knights of
the Old Republic and Ty Fire are in the
realm of bonafide classics but low
points and I mean low points have graced
us with stinkers such as Force Commander
Yoda stories lightsaber duels and
Masters of Terror skocy
I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing that
correctly but it does not matter because
that game sucked suffice it to say any
upcoming Star Wars game usually requires
a bit of cautious optimism compounding
this is the fact that respawn is also
leaving what I imagined to be its genre
comfort zone its original members made
no attempt to hide that they were
founding a shooter studio in 2012 and
each of its three releases have
reinforced that notion with fallen order
the company has made its way into
uncharted territory and it is quite a
lot of new ground not only has it
shifted to a third-person perspective
it's also introduced Souls borne
progression elements and Metroidvania
level design a more risk-averse studio
might have stuck to its guns and just
transplanted a proven formula into the
Star Wars world and I'm sure it would
have been fine but respawn is no amateur
developer and despite the risks involved
Jedi fallen order is no average Star
Wars game it only released two days ago
and falling ordered dear viewer has
already become one of my favorite Star
Wars entries to date it's definitely
rough around the edges at least at
launch and its blend of platforming
backtracking and deliberate combat don't
always mesh completely but it is a
superbly paced adventure with a vivid
cast of characters even talking about it
now I already want to replay it that's
not what this video is about though my
coworker phil has gone much more in
depth in our official review and
outlined his own thoughts on the newest
installment in the Star Wars canon you
should read it as soon as you finish
giving me your undivided attention
seriously do not leave you
we'll hook up the YouTube algorithm and
my boss might get mad
please stay anyway to me fall in order
is a statement its respawn saying yeah
we know titanfall 2 is [ __ ] sick but
we have other ambitions to consider we
want to branch into new areas we want to
prove ourselves beyond the shooter genre
even while our last release continues to
attract more and more players every
month it's not a big deal but yeah we
know we're [ __ ] killing it anyway to
boil it down for all of you list jockeys
out there respawns new release proves to
me three things one the studio is not a
one-trick pony yes the argument could be
made that apex legends already did this
considering that it ditched Titan Falls
relatively traditional structure for
that of an ongoing battle royale but
fallen order emphasizes this
adaptability even more it borrows from
genres completely new to respawn as a
group and the results speak for
themselves
respawn is slowly joining the ranks of
teams such as blizzard insomniac and the
grossly overlooked image and form as a
studio that is tough to pin down
statement part number to respawn can
hang in the big leagues I don't think
it's controversial to say that Star Wars
is the single greatest American
contribution to pop culture ever it's
Americana incarnate and corporations
have spent years wringing every possible
opportunity out of that galaxy far far
away for respawn to come along with its
Star Wars debut and outshine some major
franchise projects is proof that it can
handle the pressure of colossal
corporations and still deliver when the
time comes and that brings me to my last
point despite the risks involved just by
handling a precious global property and
despite leaving the genre it knows so
well statement part 3 is that respawn
understands its identity if you look
hard enough my friend you can see that
respawn DNA all throughout fallen order
the team's focus on movement momentum
and slick mechanics permeate almost
every aspect of Calchas toises
is journey its blend of platforming and
environmental puzzles recall the
fantastic campaign of titanfall to even
fallen orders story itself as Phil
points out in his review gains more and
more momentum as it progresses which is
all to say that respawn understands its
strengths its experimenting yes but it
understands how that semi intangible
respawn flow and elevate a game above
its genre and in this regard I'm
extremely happy it remembered its roots
so have at it respawn
bring on the turn-based strategy pump
out those RPGs give me every [ __ ]
dating simulator your collective hearts
desire make a social strand game for all
I care chances are you will nail it and
chances are I will thoroughly enjoy it
so here's to whatever's next
[Music]